throughout the country ninety percent of
city states are going to go bankrupt
within the next five years and probably
many of them sooner hi I'm Sen Cavanaugh
reason TV we're here with former Los
Angeles Mayor Richard Riordan your honor
thanks for joining us oh thanks for
having me you've been hitting the
streets a lot and publishing the op-eds
and making the argument that municipal
bankruptcy might be the way forward for
cities such as Los Angeles and maybe
specifically for Los Angeles can you
elaborate on why that would help a city
in distress well right now the pensions
that the city of Los Angeles has to pay
every year go up about five hundred
million dollars a year and this year
they just barely got by next year
they're going to have to come up with
additional 500 million dollars and I
don't know where they're going to get it
they've stolen from every nook and
cranny of the city and if they get it
next year by some miracle they won't get
at the year after so I my prediction is
there what one of two things are going
to happen one is that they're going to
have to come up with a restructuring of
the whole pension plan and everything in
the city or go bankrupt the the second
thing is they've got you got to get the
unions involved and the first i should
say the first thing that's going to
happen is that people will stop buying
la bonds from the city the states in
worse shape than the city and my
prediction is that next year come july
first they will not be able to sell any
bonds what they call a revenue
anticipation bonds to cover the next
year i don't think they'll be able to
sell them because nobody knows where
they're going to have the revenues to
pay them off and there's isn't there an
additional complication by the federal
cancellation of the buy American bonds
that were in designed to encourage
buying of municipal debt yeah there is I
mean all of a sudden has come to a
screeching halt just in the last two
months
I've been predicting it for two years
now and I sold all the bonds I had in
government because of it and all of us
everything has stayed pretty even on it
but all of a sudden the last two months
there's been a total crisis of selling
these bonds the cost to the city of La
almost the cost of their bonds for the
one year bonds went up about fifty
percent in the last year okay and that's
a pretty good indication that there's
not a lot of credit being given to
there's not well not a lot of credit but
also a big indication is that people may
be afraid to buy those bars in the case
of bankruptcies we've had two fairly
recent ones in California there's orange
county in the early 90s and vallejo in
2008 in both of those cases the the
municipality and the county did not get
out of there either public sector
pension liabilities which was the real
issue chapter 9 bankruptcy which is what
municipalities will go into allows
specifically for these contracts be
cancelled so why has no politician had
the will to do that yet because they're
elected by the unions in vallejo in the
state of California even in Orange
County the unions put more money into
elections of politicians and the biggest
corporations in the world and because of
that you go in like Vallejo they had to
make some changes in the particularly
the police pensions up there and the
police held out forever even though the
firefighters made a deal with the city
and ultimately the police union went out
and the politicians were afraid to go
ahead without it so what's going to
happen they're going to face the same
problem in another year or two mayor
Antonio Villaraigosa just recently broke
from pattern certainly he's a longtime
Union supporter and teachers union
member and yet he has recently been
thumping the tub saying that the
teachers are in the way of reform and
what does that mean what does that do
you well you know it's curious because
I've been out there within the articles
I've had in the Wall Street Journal New
York Times and other it's very critical
of me Revere Ragosa particularly on the
pensions in the future and a lot of
other issues like closing the libraries
and weekends and at nights and then he
comes up with this incredibly great talk
blaming the unions for the our poor
education system I said hallelujah I'm
going to forget everything I didn't like
about him and I think he's the greatest
mayor that ever lived now educating
children so they have the tools to
compete in a high-tech society in the
future is the best thing not only for
the children but for the country because
we can't compete with other countries we
don't have the young people who can do
the high-tech jobs that the end in India
they can do China they can do Malaysia
they can do can you tell us a little bit
about your own experience as a private
sector person in the charter school
business and the and so forth you know I
sound important more important than I
deserve but I the Alliance for charter
schools which has 18 charter schools the
average they do is about forty or fifty
percent then the schools the kids came
from they do over 800 a AP is and it was
founded in nineteen eighty eight by
helen bernstein and myself and helen was
a former head of the teachers union who
got religion on reform and we started
with the Alliance a program called learn
which was to get more power down at the
local school level with the teachers and
the parents and everybody that worked it
didn't work extremely well and improved
things by maybe eight percent and then
while I was mayor frank baxter took over
as chairman of the Alliance and the laws
were put through Sacramento allowing for
charter schools so Frank changed the
emphasis of the Alliance to charter
schools and since then and say we formed
18 charter schools at the Alliance I
took over for Frank when he became after
I was mayor and he became ambassador to
Europe
way and he did a great job Alliance did
a great job we built a great board of
directors some of our schools do over
900 API the vast vast majority well over
ninety percent go to four-year colleges
of kids and ninety-five percent the kids
are a below poverty they do much better
than Beverly Hills or San Marino or any
of those communities and then last
September I got a call saying that I SEF
which is a group of about 15 charter
schools which is fantastic
scholastically virtually every student
is african-american over ninety percent
of the students end up going to
four-year colleges and that I got a call
saying they were about to close because
they've run out of money and what
happened is what i call the perfect
storm happening at a time when the state
had cut down on the money that went into
education and therefore the cash flow to
the school had gone down dramatically
add that to that the fact that the i sep
grew too fast and they put a lot of
their operation money into building new
schools plus the fact that they just did
some stupid things economically they had
run out of money so about three days
before the friday we had to they were
going to close Mike Pisco who founded
ice F and as to me as a saint he was a
terrible manager but a saint came to me
begging to see if I could do something
because he had been to the Gates
Foundation the Walton foundation a
number of other big foundations and they
had seen they did they said we don't
want to give money down a dark hole okay
something that's going under he came to
me and click my mind I say two things
one I can't believe letting these kids
go back to schools were only four
percent of the kids are going to
four-year colleges compared to ICF that
was ninety percent and secondly if I CF
failed it would reflect on every charter
school
would really hurt the charter school
movement so I said anything I can do we
should do it we should do it now so with
three days to go we raised three million
dollars to keep the school going that
month since then we've gotten that up to
over 10 and a half men where we were
able to pay those months and we have
enough to get us through December we
need to raise another two man for
January and once we're through January
the school will be able to go on its own
two feet and I'll maybe if you're
interested I'll tell you why but the
bottom line is they will be able to
stand on their own two feet what's
fundraising environment like these days
well it's very very tough I mean it's a
lot of the people that I usually rely on
said no and I think it's sort of an
experience I mean I grew up as a lawyer
I did a lot of you know near type
bankruptcy work for sick companies and
the one thing you ever real learned is
don't put money into a sec company
unless they have a total complete change
of Management and thing because they
will figure some way to lose that money
that you give them and I think a lot of
the really great foundations thought
that way they said we're not going to
give you any money you come back a few
months or now prove that you can stand
on your own two feet well we needed
money in the meantime and so it was
tough but I went out Eli Broad has come
up came up with two men which will most
of which will come in in December and
the Otis booth foundation came up with
two million I came up with two million
myself and a whole bunch of other angels
like the Gates Foundation gave a few
hundred thousand and so we are you know
we're getting there how receptive has
the V Ragosa administration been to
charter schools well they've been mixed
the very Gosa was very mixed until he
gave that speech and he realized you
know he has taken over they caught the
mayor's partnership he finally woke up
to the fact that the reason
it wasn't competing with ICF or the
Alliance is the union's the union's
getting the union's do not want any
accountability they put in competent
adults ahead of children that's the way
it works in my family to the the
Democrats have shown some some pretty
broad disenchantment with teachers
unions and public sector unions in
particular of late and you know that
government goes starting with Governor
Brown governor-elect Brown what does
this mean when you have this broad
consensus among the Republicans and the
Democrats and the the people that these
organizations are really taking up too
much of our money standing the way of
reform and yet nothing changes I would
call it a broad consensus yet because
clearly if you take like Sacramento the
legislature there is still
overwhelmingly controlled by the unions
but there's a break in the ice for it
like Bureau Gosa coming in Obama through
Arne Duncan the race to the top has come
in people think that Governor Brown may
come in he at charter school that he
supported in Oakland but the legislators
are all there they're elected because
the unions they're afraid to vote
against the unions but I'm hoping that
what V Ragosa did could be the atomic
bomb that will wake everybody up
particularly poor people and say my
child has a right to go to college my
child has a right to upward mobility to
be anything they want I don't want this
kind of education so talk a little more
about the the city and its finances a
lot of folks on the Left will say that
the problem with LA with California with
the United States is that the rich are
not paying their fair share in taxes is
that it is the problem that we could we
solve our financial problems by taxing
the rich more well the answer is
absolutely not and I'm a rich guy so I
can you know I live extremely well
I do give well over half of my wealth to
charities and particularly for anything
dealing with poor children and a lot of
rich people do that Eli Broad you look
what he he's done even Bill Gates who
has has done it but the cat it's an
interesting problem that people don't
understand they don't want a lot of
people is the gap between the rich and
the poor has grown every year since 1970
and I think it's growing faster now with
technology the wealthy people like
myself control the companies that build
technology and that I think gap is going
to get bigger and bigger and bigger and
unless we educate kids to be able to be
executives top employees and everything
in high technology those kids are going
to have nowhere to go 10 years from now
they'll be poor they'll be out a job and
they'll probably be revolting unless we
figure out some way to solve the problem
you cannot solve the problem by saying
okay we're going to redistribute because
raising taxes is a way of redistributing
redistributing the wealth every place in
the world that's every tried that has
been a dismal failure you look at
England in the 50s they had a brain
drain where the wealthy moved including
the Beatles moved out of the country and
by the end of the 50s England was
bankrupt Margaret Thatcher saved them in
that time and you saw Chile under el y
ND I mean God hit within a year he like
doubled the income of the poor and
within a year the whole country was
bankrupt in the case of LA what would be
a smarter tax policy what could we do in
the way we collect taxes in LA to to
make the city more competitive I think
you asked the wrong question is how do
you make the city more competitive as a
right question and you do it by having a
city with bureaucrats and the City
Council the mayor being friendly to
business and we have since I left office
we have become less and less friendly to
business the bureaucrats take over you
talk to small businesses or any business
it takes them forever to get permits to
start a business in LA who wants to
start a business in Los Angeles forget
the amount of taxes being a wealthy guy
I don't mind paying more taxes if
they're going to do the right thing but
I don't know if you ever heard of a see
Northcote Parkinson yes yeah he had a
magic thing if the total taxes go over
twenty-five percent a lot of bad things
happen the rich can right now in this
internet age rich can run their company
from any place in the world they don't
have to be in California they don't have
to be in the United States and you make
the taxes at a certain point up there
that's what they're doing now to a great
extent they're doing it anyway because
California and particularly LA are
unfriendly to business and we haven't
created an infrastructure who haven't
done virtually nothing for an
infrastructure in the last 30 years and
a lot of companies have left they've
expanded how many apple and Intel other
companies have expanded outside of the
United States or at least outside of
California let's speak a little bit
you're talking about infrastructure I
just took me about an hour to drive over
here from Hollywood how important is
mobility to a city like LA and how much
is the you know the fairly grueling
experience of being on the roads in LA
depressing the city's future I mean
certainly in deciding whether you're
going to locate a business or expand a
business LA traffic is important
ingredient and I think it's got to be
improved but how much you can improve a
city the size i don't know you have the
city council control the entitlements to
build new buildings the ozone ii and
they each councilman essentially is a
dictator because if if the other
councilmen don't vote for what they want
in their district you won't
them in their other district so
essentially that the big developers are
getting permits to build all these big
new condo buildings and everything in
areas that shouldn't have we don't want
anybody else living there because it
just brings more and more traffic it
gets awfully complicated because you
know the developers don't make money by
putting things in the inner city you
know there is some public housing it
goes there at some astronomical cost
which doesn't make much sense and you
also complicate a thing as you see a lot
of gentrifying of the inner city so
you're pushing like the number of blacks
in LA it has been reduced by I don't
know it's almost fifty percent in the
last twenty years so it's very
complicated I don't claim to be able to
see through walls and predict where
we're going to be next year or two or
ten years after but I'll tell you as a
leader whoever is in a leadership role
ought to be studying this and bringing
on the smartest people in the world to
help them are the smartest people in the
world really going to going to solve the
problem that we're talking about right
here let's let's take South LA where
there are a ton of programs that that
stem from the time of the riots and
areas like marlton square and the
Vermont Manchester project and there's
some you know Broadway I forgot the
cross street is a lot of huge projects
that are fallow to this day everybody
has looked at them everybody has come in
with these big plans the CRA has always
been involved and year after year they
continue to Bruce literally nothing but
prairie land in the middle of Los
Angeles why is that wouldn't it be
better just to to say let's let's divide
all of this up into a few hundred little
lots sell it to whoever wants to buy it
and build a house well clearly things
like that would definitely be the answer
one of the problems I mean it's a
problem it's it's a fact is a lot of
that land is in the hands of very
wealthy people and they are looking for
some magical way that they can make an
awful lot more money off projects
particularly by getting government money
involved etc
now under my administration we came up
with a program called Genesis which was
to try to get the private sector not
public money but get the private sector
into the inner cities and not handcuff
them by saying oh you have to hire half
your employees from the inner city or
this and the other just do what makes
money for everybody because the inner
city needs they need better grocery
stores and things like that there but
the way to get it is not through so I
call poverty pimps but through people
that know how to make money and will
make money there and Genesis has done a
great great job they've actually
expanded throughout the country they've
got several billion dollars of
development and it's improved actually
the work they've done has improved it in
LA as well as other cities personal
question you uh you're a friend of the
legendary comedian Jonathan winters yeah
he's a creeper as he told you any good
jokes lately anything on point well I'm
wondering if he you know he's a little
crazy sometimes and he is still going
strong and he he is there's a drug store
and cafe they're all in one business and
montecito that he stays out at and some
of it done some outrageous things there
like some woman comes into the drugstore
with her husband and says oh you're
Jonathan winters and said no ma'am no
I'm a doctor seymour hersh I'm head of
the Santa Barbara Health Institute she'd
don't know you look just like why can't
they wear well no ma'am I appreciate
that and he said is that your husband
over there oh yeah that's my husband you
know he has a terminal disease and that
but his craziness he won't let go it was
funny for a second but yeah yeah one
more thing on the mobility before we get
off that I we're in LA where there is
the Expo Line exposition line is going
to run from USC I think although maybe
all the way to the beach hope at street
level it's a it's a street grade train
now we have this new multi bazillion
dollar plan for the sub wait not to the
sea but the subway to the VA
hospital and so when is LA going to get
over its train fantasy well it is a
fantasy although the the line to the
beach on exposition makes pretty good
economic sense because it's infinitely
cheaper than a subway when the let me
back off when I was mayor we went down
with zev yaroslavsky Vaughn Burke and
myself went down to court she bore
Brazil southern Brazil where the
previous mayor of the city and then the
governor of the province that's in Jaime
Lerner was a Polish Jewish guy whose
family came over the 1920s to Brazil
they've been there for years and was an
architect he was a trained architect and
then his successor I think it was tan
Gucci or something's Japanese the same
that come over the 1930s was an
architect and they designed to me the
best design city in the world per dollar
because it wasn't fancy at all but they
had everything coming into the middle of
the city in rungs those rungs were
dedicated bus lanes where they had tri
articulated buses with which can be
doubled and everything with about 250
people they took that took off every 7
70 seconds from the center and went off
one of those spokes the only high-rises
could be along the the bus lanes and no
place else and they also had like things
that look like lighthouses in there all
the park to show where the parks were so
what we did we came back and we copied
what they did in the valley we have a
15-mile bus lane there that costs about
three percent of what the subway will
per mile and it carry a lot more because
this is the orange line the orange line
because what happens is that there you
have only a 70 second difference between
one bus and the
other and with subways you have about 10
or 15 minute difference even though the
subway goes faster you can't take more
people and the one going to the beach or
to the VA is crazy and I don't think
it's ever going to happen I mean among
other thing you got to compete with
Beverly Hills and you know Santa Monica
somewhere along in it and I don't even
if it's built by some magic at some
astronomical price I don't think it's
going to do that much jiminy hope for
California as a sort of test case as
this kind of Keynesian interventionist
laboratory where we have everything the
Democrats are in control the Republicans
have been extinguished the threshold for
raising taxes has been lowered the every
really every aspect of human behavior
has some regulation over it there are a
million environmental regulations
there's a high-speed rail effort so
how's it all going to end up well I
think the total collapse unless
something's done now what's going to
happen not just to California can happen
more in California others but throughout
the country ninety percent of city
states are going to go bankrupt within
the next five years and probably many of
them sooner the big thing they won't be
able to sell raise money by selling
bonds nobody wants to lend the money so
the federal government if Obama wants to
get reelected he's going to face some
part of this because some of them
happened before 2012 and you'll have
total disarray the parks will be closed
the libraries will be closed they'll cut
down twenty five percent or more on the
number of police and it'll be a total
collapse and one thing the Obama
administration has not focused on this
what's your assessment of Governor
Schwarzenegger oh do you know hey he and
I you know I love the guy but copper you
know he won't play golf with me anymore
why won't the governor play golf with
you I've heard about this can I be
totally honest with you yeah you're not
going to repeat this to your wife right
absolutely not would you play cough with
anybody
who cheats on the scorecard on almost
every other hole would you know I
wouldn't would you play golf with
somebody who hits the ball in the woods
and it mysteriously ends up in the
middle of the fairway wood you know no
of course not well neither will Arnold
okay what do I think I appreciate coming
clean on that Arnold is I you know he's
a good friend of mine although we've had
differences recently on some of the
bonds and things that they wanted to do
like I can't last a year ago may I will
was chairman against voting for all the
lottery and all this money they were
going to steal but our oath is a cream
Leibrandt obviously very charismatic and
a real doer and I saw him in private
life that way helping inner-city causes
he didn't just pay lip service he would
do it get it done he got up into
Sacramento where he had all these great
ideas and you had a legislature that was
controlled by the unions so if you
wanted to do things on education the
Union stopped you and and then he had to
make some peace with the unions and then
the Republicans would stop him and I
shouldn't say I feel sorry for him but
because I don't think he feels sorry for
himself I will say you know I was
Secretary of Education up there for a
while and there were a few things that I
would like to have seen done that maybe
the governor could do you go back into
the city of La were when I was mayor I
was called a very weak mayoral system
and although i got a new charter into
place my second term which made it a
little stronger but the bottom line is
if you have perceived power as mayor
then just use it don't let any button
don't wait for questions as to whether
you have the legal or other right to do
it if you have if people perceive you
have that
and if what you're doing is ethical and
practical just do it like you've heard
the saying it's much easier to get
forgiveness than to get permission you
let's take the earthquake northridge
earthquake literally I had zero power
that and then legally because the state
constitution provided in emergencies
that the county would take over but I
acted like I had all the power the
county never questioned me the state
never questioned me the federal
government never questioned me the
county I mean did they even know there
was an earthquake welcome yeah and
that's that's surprising to me that I
would have thought I'd never studied how
the the you know emergency power for
vested but I would assume that it would
go to the mayor not the county which has
no executive yeah you with it it would
make sense right yeah how about a V
Ragosa what do you have any thoughts on
I mean other than turning on the unions
well right now he's on my a list because
those right 30 on and I've talked to a
lot of the leaders in town business
leaders who are reformists on education
and all of a sudden they're in love with
me Ragosa because he could be the the
nuclear bomb to really destroy help us
start destroying the power of these
unions where they say they put
incompetent people ahead of children
they want no accountability so I say all
the things I've been critical of Bureau
goes on I'm just clear out of my mind
now right now I'm hugging him or kissing
him and I'm going to work with them in
fact I I'm meeting with him this
afternoon on this whole subject that's
speaking of forgiveness and permission
you've you've been divorced three times
years you're still listed as Roman
Catholic are you practicing very much so
yeah and I on the Catholic Archdiocese
Educational Foundation and so does the
church bother about divorce anymore i
mean i remember it being a big deal
breaker well they make it easier to get
back in the church they do but they
don't you know approve of you know they
don't like divorce
and it early enough when the girls I'm
dating now was my first wife the mother
of my children Jeanne and we get along
very very well and she much to my
amazement she doesn't remember all my
bad thing she remembered my great sense
of humor I have two very grudgingly
admit as a disgruntled former LA Times
staffer that they have really done some
important work in 2010 as you know I'm
hardly anybody reads it anymore but it
still exercises an enormous amount of
influence in local politics and in State
Politics where does the bias show up in
the other times can you give me some
examples of if maybe from your own
administration well when I'm
administration they had I was running
for office they had there was a reporter
from a Dallas newspaper followed me
around one day from house to house and I
was in some house in LA and there was
this woman or 90s was there and we sat
down and chatted with the reporter and
you know finally she said something like
you know blacks are terrible and and my
response was well you know some of them
are and you know I wasn't going to come
out and hit her in the nose or something
and so this reporter in a 33 her
articles on three pages in the very back
page near the end talks about this
little capsule the LA Times the front
page a section and headlines starts out
with that and say people accuse riordan
of racism now it made me angry and is
still and i think about it and they just
they were trying to find almost anything
to you know there's no way a rich white
Republican can care about the poor and
but I will say that I I had I've had
hundreds and hundreds of Democrats come
up to me and say I'm first Republican
I've ever voted for because I do care
about poor kids and to me that was the
most important goal as mayor was to help
poor children
what was it like when you were growing
up with what's your background I went to
a you know primary school to
kindergarten through second grade we're
fifty percent of my classmates were
black and interesting enough compared
they were of the equal of the whites I'm
enix elastically and even though I lived
in a middle to upper middle-class
neighborhood on one side of woods on the
other side with the blacks with these
very poor housing but you know they did
well in school we got a log all alone
with their parents they got along with
mine although I thought ten years later
I thought you know my parents never met
each other here but my parents who had
you know average amount of bigoted ISM
at the time never once said anything one
other thing on the Elliott engine is the
bias that we're talking about it's
really on sometimes it's on particular
politicians but the overall kind of
momentum of the institution is always in
favor of government intervention and
against any sort of private sector
initiative it why is that especially
since it's one of the few non-union
papers in the country well it really is
Union I mean the sense that they give an
awful lot not to be Union they pay out
more than they should and I think it's
well obviously it's the average reporter
is very liberal and you have you know
reported to graduated from Columbia
Journalism school and others tended to
be the professors at the school were
liberal they tended to be very little
and it just cut through the whole system
and after Otis Chandler came in and said
okay we're going to give power to the
reporters and everything everything
changed we're before one person at the
top could say you're going to put
everything conservative in the newspaper
do you think that the paper actually
lost some influence by doing that
because it seems to me I was a big when
I was there I used to love their archive
system and just look and read these
crazy editorials from back in the old
days and you know it was the paper that
made Nick
up until Otis came in now Otis comes in
turns it into this nationally
competitive paper but actually kind of
in a lot of ways reduce the influence of
the paper it's just another come it's
like it's another thing behind the New
York Times yeah I think it is a lot of
things the but i think particularly the
conservatives in town are among the
wealthier generally and they stop taking
the LA Times you know they lost a
constituency we're at minimum they could
have had more right wing left wing or
you know if you give both sides of the
equation now New York Times is worse
than the LA Times that way and even
there they're hurting now very badly but
son look back since we're speaking about
the the institution of newspapers to
think back a little bit you come in as
mayor in 1993 at the time nobody's on
the internet riots have just happened
the entertainment the LA Times any
entertainment mahna you know goliaths
are all at the peak of their powers how
would you stack up you know your own
mayoral t against where la is today Bri
of the world and that's what you're
asking me because you know I can sound
to say well I was the greatest mayor in
the history of the world and if I had
any branch it was the ability to hire
the best and the brightest people and to
empower them the word empowerment very
few politicians know how to empower
other people but if you empower people
and you say like I told my average staff
even right down to the middle or lower
middle when you come into every morning
think what can I do that to make la a
better City not what's going to make the
mayor look good or what I agree on and
by doing that you attract better and
better people around you because they
say well you're empowered we can get
things done and we did what you know we
got tremendous things done and
particularly for business I mean getting
down to where 95
% of permitting could have been done on
the Internet in five minutes and the
others within a lesson you know two or
three months where it might take years
before what happened with that I mean
since then you you had mayors that
didn't know how to empower people and
essentially surround themselves with
very mediocre people and I think what
happens is the bureaucrats just sort of
drifted off in whatever direction they
wanted la's political class and it's all
and it's almost entirely democratic at
this point is really I mean it's a south
of the mason-dixon line level of
politics in a way that I think would
shock Americans in other places is there
any hope for for you know just la's
political class and maybe specifically
for the Republicans is there anything
that can happen to kind of shake things
up you know you would think so that
because usually you know the Republicans
go towards the middle the Democrats go
through as a metal and you get a pretty
balanced type legislature but it hasn't
happened it's gotten worse as you point
out and where it's going to be I don't
know but if there's disaster in the city
is the politicians going to change or
the public going to realize we have to
elect different people I hope it's the
latter you had privatization initiative
when you were mayor maybe hasn't gone
too far since you've left office what
what what areas of la government are
right for privatization well I mean you
start out with that you have you know 99
percent of the elected officials in LA
or were supported by the unions and
they're not about and privatization to a
great extent would indicate that the
unions are going to lose a lot of power
now therefore I don't feel great hope
for the future but with that as the
budget gets more and more trouble some
of the solutions may the only solutions
may be
ization so they might do that just for
that reason to get out of going to into
bankruptcy is like privatize the airport
the poor it's other places like that and
certainly with the way the public
employees have just gobbled up every
penny of taxes and everything in the
country it seems to me that it's about
the only way out of this morass is to
privatize